on average americans spend 87 of their
time indoors
but what if you ditched that last bit
and gave up the great outdoors for good
odds are you've been stuck at home
before maybe because of bad weather
maybe there's a pandemic in your self
teeth you probably wouldn't notice a
huge difference at first
other than a bit of cabin fever but
after a week and a half
things may start to change ironically
after spending all that time indoors you
may start to feel
tired no matter how much sleep you get
you see
being stuck inside limits the amount of
sunlight you get
normally when sunlight hits your eyes it
signals to your brain to stop producing
a hormone called melatonin
and that hormone affects your circadian
rhythm which regulates sleep
without a reliable sunlight trigger your
body will just keep making melatonin
and it might start to feel tired all the
time
sunlight is also a trigger for your body
to produce serotonin
aka the happy hormone it helps to
regulate your mood among other things
so without enough sunlight after a few
months your melatonin levels will rise
in your serotonin levels those may drop
along with your mood
it's this combination of decreased
sunlight in serotonin that's credited as
one of the main causes of seasonal
affective disorder
or sad it's a type of depression that is
most prevalent during long dark months
sad is relatively uncommon but it may
increase if we all stay locked in our
homes you may be thinking you can just
bring in artificial sunlight like
a light box well this has been shown to
reduce the effects of sad
but not curious and it wouldn't really
matter because your mood can be affected
by another important factor
the great outdoors just being outside in
general has been linked to lower stress
levels
so say goodbye to staying calm and hello
to higher blood pressure
plus that inside air is stale the
environmental protection agency says
it's up to
five times more polluted than the air
outdoors this isn't good news for your
lungs
over time breathing in that recycled air
could increase your risk for illnesses
linked to pollution
and four months to a year down the road
your body is going to start missing
something vital to your health
vitamin d this is essential for optimal
health
bone strength and muscular regulation in
order to make vitamin d
active you need sunlight and artificial
won't do
when ultraviolet b rays hit cholesterol
in your skin
energy is released and that fuels the
production of vitamin d
without that production though your
vitamin d levels will start to drop
and if you don't do anything to counter
this decrease you might find yourself
losing strength or getting depressed
while your bones gradually become
weaker vitamin d is also important for
regulating your immune system
so you could be at a higher risk of
catching illnesses too
the next development is a little hard to
predict since vitamin d levels
vary from person to person but you may
start seeing some very serious issues
in a few years lower levels of vitamin d
could put you at a higher risk of
developing heart disease or strokes
plus an increased risk of cancers
fractured bones
and serious tooth decay years down the
road you might feel some pain
specifically in your bones and hips
you could even have difficulty walking
finding yourself waddling or
swaying precariously now vitamin d
supplements may or may not help
replenish that loss of activated vitamin
d
but even with that help you might
struggle from a lack of mental
stimulation
in other words you'll be bored the
monotony of everyday life
in the same place doing the same things
over and over again without stepping
outdoors
that may all start to take a toll if you
don't have to go outside
you're likely to become more sedentary
meaning you'll exercise less
and research has shown that even a short
12-minute walk can reduce symptoms of
depression
and help you cope with stress this could
be worse if you live by yourself
social isolation and loneliness have
been linked to conditions like high
blood pressure
heart disease anxiety and depression and
if you're quarantined
you could be dealing with a range of
psychological stressors
resulting in undesirable symptoms like
low mood and irritability
along with insomnia and depression all
made worse by the fact that you'll be
inside
day after day doing the same thing so
maybe if you can go and take a walk
outside
and if you can't well try staying active
open a window to let fresh air in find
ways to bring more sunlight into your
home so you don't mess up your sleep
schedule
it also wouldn't hurt to form a support
system to keep you connected with the
outside world
set up video chats or call your family
and friends others might be going
through a similar experience
and bonding over it could be validating
giving you what you need
to get through
[Music]